[Applause]
okay we gotta talk so this is one of
those things that it happened I didn't
think it was gonna make a video on it
and then the more I thought about the
more like no I do actually need to talk
about this so I need to talk about JK
Rowling's latest thing that she said
about Dumbledore and his relationship
with Grindelwald so MS Rowling I want
you to know that what I'm about to say
is coming from a fan I'm you know this
is not idle I'm I've been a Harry Potter
fan since the summer of 2001 when I read
the first book and burned through the
available ones right away washed all the
movies read the remaining books as they
came out and I have greatly enjoyed this
series and and what's been put out and I
I can understand how we got to where we
are right now with lgbtq+
depictions in your world but we need to
talk about them because you have now
gone on record and said some more
details and I'm going to read some of
them because I don't want to
misrepresent your words so what was said
in regards to Dumbledore and Grindelwald
their relationship was incredibly
intense it was passionate it was a love
relationship but as happens in any
relationship gay or straight or whatever
label we want to put on it
no one knows really what the other
person is feeling
you can't know you can believe you know
so I'm less interested in the sexual
side though I believe there is
a sexual dimension to this relationship
that I am in the sense of the emotions
they felt for each other which
ultimately is the most fascinating thing
about a human relationship now here's
the thing you're not wrong but your
wording makes me concerned but that's
also very very secondary because and I
mean this with as much respect as I can
muster please stop talking now I can
understand why you might be confused or
frustrated because you know when you
first talked about the fact that
Dumbledore was gay which I for one am
prepared to grant you the benefit of the
doubt and believe you when you say that
was always in your mind writing the
character there are people who will
claim that it was a retcon you were
applying I don't believe that I am
prepared to believe that that was always
in your mind but it was not met explicit
in the text and I can even work with
that given that the texts were from
Harry's perspective there isn't really a
reason why he would have known that so I
can roll with all that and at the time
you initially said it which was what
2008 9 it was before it was there was
the the tail end of that decade it was
met with surprise but also it was a very
welcomed revelation for members of the
lgbtq+ community it was a confirmation
that oh my god we exist not only do we
exist one of the iconic biggest and most
important characters in this world it's
one of us and you were praised for that
by and large and it must be frustrating
for you to now be getting shouted at and
finger wave towards by the same
community that used to praise you the
thing is the climate the world and the
community and the expectations have
changed your approach to representation
has not
and what you did initially in telling us
that was a big deal at that time ten
years or so later that is not only not a
big deal it's also not enough not when
you are providing us new works featuring
this character and continue to not make
it text now I don't feel like I should
have to get into why it is important to
actually make Dumbledore sexuality texts
if you're going to continue to bring it
up in interviews or separate from the
works itself but maybe I do because the
way you worded your statement saying
that you're more interested in the
emotions than the sex so are we when we
say we want explicit representation it's
not explicit as in sexually explicit you
know adult content only that's not what
we're talking about but it has to be it
has to be an undeniable it needs to be
in the text stated plainly in some way
not vaguely hinted at not danced on and
for the love of God not said by the
author in a way that you wouldn't have
known or identified this if all you did
was take in the work so when I say
please stop talking I don't mean shut up
I mean act because all you've been doing
for the last decade is telling us
reassuring us oh there's a there's a gay
person really there is no no that
relationship super important
oh it's important to me it's important
to him it's important to the world give
us evidence of that you have burned
through your goodwill in terms of being
able to get the benefit of the doubt
from us because you have you have been
providing us nothing
creet and I say that as someone who
honestly if nothing had been said at any
point and I simply watched the crimes of
Grindelwald it would still not be a very
good movie I'm sorry
it isn't but the hinting towards
Dumbledore Grindelwald is not poorly
handled but in the wake of your
continued claims that Dumbledore is in
fact gay it is insufficient because you
need to understand that right now the
impression that you are giving and I am
trying very hard not to accuse you of
this myself but certainly the impression
that you are giving and the way that you
are behaving is consistent with somebody
who wishes to have the recognition and
the praise that comes with diversity
inclusion but does not want to risk
alienating potential readers or viewers
by actually including it specifically in
the work that you are producing so you
get to try and placate us by assuring us
that no really there are gay people
while at the same time anyone who does
not like that idea is not forced to deal
with the fact that there are gay people
here because it is not clearly displayed
in the work in the films in the books
because until it is as far as I'm
concerned this entire notion that
Dumbledore is gay it's fan theory and
yes the author can have fan theory
because if what you're claiming is not
specifically backed up by textual
evidence then what you are claiming
about this work is no more inherently
valid than any fan theory because you're
just throwing out speculation without
evidence
you can try and claim the authority of
the author but you've been doing that
for too long now we're not gonna grant
you that authority anymore you don't get
to tell us
that Dumbledore is gay and never show it
and have a swallow it anymore and I
don't like saying this
I love these stories I love this series
I want the movies to get better again
but I don't I don't like to feel
manipulated and taken for granted and
taken advantage of I devoted a video a
little while back about the lack of
representation and brought it down to
numbers and I noted then I'll note it
again here I would not be hammering on
the Wizarding World in the world of
harry potter to include explicit lgbtq+
representation if you yourself had not
brought that up i don't demand inclusion
in everything if a creator doesn't see a
place for somebody like me or someone
who is gay or lesbian or bisexual or
transgender or asexual or genderqueer or
gender fluid which is what I am or
anything else if they don't see a place
for them they're not obligated to
represent them or me but you brought it
up you told us that we were there you
told us that we exist in this world and
you have been saying that now for a
decade and you won't prove it and there
are and have been and will continue to
be people who will make excuses for you
about how this is intended for kids
about how these stories are currently
set in the 20s about all these things
none of which precludes your ability to
just make it clear how I don't know I'm
not going to tell you how it's your
creation you're the author but you have
been claiming and now continue to claim
and keep doubling down
on this claim stop because at this point
even if we get the explicit clear
representation of Dumbledore as a gay
man in the next film that we need at
this point you still shouldn't have said
this because Unni if you're taking
action you need to let those actions
speak for themselves because your words
don't carry weight right now and until
you do commit some actions that back
them up they won't carry weight so even
if you've given the next script that
you've written it's there and it's
already there and you know it's gonna
show up you still shouldn't have said it
stop talking make it real then let it
speak for itself because this phantom
representation this author headcanon
representation it's not enough anymore
and it doesn't become more than that
until we see it so until we see it
please stop talking about it people may
ask you just say wait and see the next
film
or if you're still not gonna show it if
it's not in the next film and you did
this anyways if you said oh yes it was
real and it was sexual and it's still
not made clear in whatever the next film
is called I won't have words anymore I
will be too frustrated and disappointed
to speak kindly so most likely I will
choose to not speak at all I say that
but then I know me I'll have something
to say but either do it or don't in an
either case please stop talking about it
that's all for this one thank you for
listening I do not presume that miss
Rowling actually will view this so those
of you who did stuck to the end thank
you
a bunch of links down in the
descriptions you know buttons they do
things links they take you places such
as the patreon and there's other links
to check out besides I've written stuff
you can buy it there's merch give it a
look down in the description or don't
you don't have to it's okay because at
the end of the day it's you for the
council and I just run the meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]